I think the value of money actually is
going to be can continue to diminish
we'll see what happens with that I mean
Michael burry we talked about the other
day made a big bet against the S P 500
and NASDAQ and so everyone's kind of
like looking around like does he know
something exactly he doesn't mean he
does he got he got the mortgage-backed
Securities things right in 2008 doesn't
mean he's a prophet means he got one big
one right
I don't know I don't know if I want to
hope he's right this time or not I mean
a shock to the system could be good it
could be bad I have no idea I think
ultimately the scary thing is it's going
to negatively impact working-class
people who are already having a hard
enough time buying groceries
yeah I just like to know when that's
going to happen
second plan well a SpaceX what SpaceX
sold all their Bitcoin today or
something like that are they really and
then the price of Bitcoin collapsed and
then they announced ETF ethereum ETF or
whatever Futures and then it jumped back
up so it's like yeah everyone would have
loved to have known that SpaceX was
about to sell off their Bitcoin so they
could get out before price went down but
yeah everything dropped six percent